you get the sense that Twitter really
didn't think it through now I'm talking
about the decision to hit one of
president Trump's tweets with an absurd
fact check now it wasn't just that
Twitter was wrong on the merits but it
revealed the staggering hypocrisy of its
supposed mission not only are they
attempting to editorialize and now
censor the President of the United
States they do so while allowing Chinese
propaganda accounts to run free on their
platform well today the president
responded warning that he would move to
regulate social media platforms that try
to silence conservative voices and he
plans to sign an executive order on the
subject tomorrow but even before that
news is Missouri senator Josh Hawley
called on the government to revoke
liability protections for social media
companies which would drastically change
how they're treated senator Hawley joins
us exclusively tonight senator explain
for our audience how your proposed
action would affect these entities well
it would just take away the special deal
Lord that they currently get from the
government there's a reason the Twitter
and Facebook and Google have gotten so
big and powerful a huge it's not because
of free market competition it's because
of the lack of free market competition
because the government has given them a
special deal that Fox News doesn't get
and the New York Times doesn't get no
traditional publisher gets they are free
from liability free from suit they've
got a special immunity and here's the
thing if they're gonna act like regular
publishers if Twitter is gonna
editorialize about the president the
United States then they ought to be
treated like a regular publisher and
that's what my bill would do well I
think there seems to be some opposition
within the social media world to that as
Mark Zuckerberg spoke out today and and
he said that's basically that's not what
we do at Facebook does that give you a
sense that well they've gotten the
message pretty quickly that you go down
this road it's gonna be a rocky one for
you I think that Zuckerberg is clearly
quite eager to throw Twitter under the
us here because Zuckerberg doesn't want
to lose immunities for Facebook I mean
they want to keep their special deal I'm
surprised that Google isn't out there
doing the same thing problem is is that
Google has also been censoring Americans
who criticize the Chinese Communist
Party so these guys really all do this
stuff they've just gotten by with it for
a long time they picked on the president
Twitter did this time and that's really
elevated what they're doing is that they
are editorializing they are censoring
they are making political judgments and
yet they're claiming that oh no no we're
not like traditional media we should be
treated differently we're neutral we
don't have any opinions we just post
other people's opinions it just isn't
true Laura and it's time to start
calling them out on us well when you
look at the head of the site integrity
it's called
this guy we looked into his past as as
some others this guy yeol Roth has a
history of tweets that called Trump a
racist tangerine that's just right after
the inauguration he said there were
actual Nazis in the White House and it
might not surprise you to learn senator
that he donated of course to Hillary's
presidential campaign and he says
Twitter though is working to limit the
spread of potentially harmful and
misleading content so why haven't his
tweets then have why weren't they
labeled as harmful personal attacks it's
exactly standard or how about the
Chinese foreign ministry Laura who've
been out there on Twitter on social
media saying that United States soldiers
actually started the coronavirus who've
been out there saying that Beijing has
done nothing wrong with relation to
kovat 19 that they took every available
health measure these are just outright
lies and falsehoods and to impugn the
integrity of United States soldiers as
the as the originators of the corona
virus you crazy at Twitter hasn't had a
word to say about any of those things
this is a joke this is Twitter showing
their political bias and again if they
want to editorialize like the New York
Times go right on ahead you can do that
that's free country they're a free
company but they shouldn't get a special
deal from government because of it
senator are you shocked about just how
willing so many in the media are to
carry the water of the Chinese common
party when indeed history of abuse
subjugation oppression torture of
political dissidents and yet Trump is
the problem on the world stage are you
surprised by this yeah I really am I
mean particularly when you see what
they're doing right now in Hong Kong
lorry you can see their intentions
really laid bare you know trying to said
that Beijing said they were going to
improve democracy in Hong Kong and prove
it by ending it of course and now
they've got their thugs out there on the
streets they want a strip Hong Kong of
all of its liberties take away their
judiciary take away their right to
assemble and you see what they did with
kovat 19 I mean they unleash this
pandemic on the world because they were
too incompetent and also frankly too too
evil to deal with it I mean they would
not admit what they were doing they
would not admit they had a health
problem on their hands they suppress the
information and because of this this
thing was allowed to spread into a
global pandemic so they have they are
responsible Laura for all kinds of
wrongdoing and yet you see the media
giving them like with Twitter giving
them a free pass while they focus on the
president United States it's crazy
well senator we can't wait to see what
happens next and we'll be looking for
the president's executive order tomorrow
thank you so much for joining us tonight
thank you